>> RAMSDALE: All right, looks like we got
a packed house. This is fantastic. I've actually
been to a lot of these conferences and I've
never seen one and with such enthusiasm and
such attendance. So this is fantastic. I hope
you guys are having a good time so far. And
I hope you're learning a lot about Google
Technologies. I noticed some faces from my
earlier sessions, this is great. We'll just
carry on where we left off. For those of you
who didn't attend the first session, if you're
interested, we're going to post these online.
But the way I've got to lay it out, I think
will give you a good idea of what's going
on even if you didn't attend the first session.
So, my name is Chris Ramsdale. I work in Developer
Relations with the Google Web Toolkit Team.
And today, I'm going to start taking about
how to build Business Apps with the Spring
Technologies that we integrate it with. So
we started off in the keynote talking a little
bit about this today and I gave about a five
minute overview. So, I'm going to dig a little
bit deeper in today, and then we're going
to try to expand out on what it means to actually
build business applications. So a brief agenda,
you know, I had this worked around and I kept
moving the agenda around until I got comfortable
with it. And I had demos towards the end to
kind of wrap things up. And I thought to myself,
you know, it's weird when we talk about business
applications and enterprise applications,
it varies greatly. Sometimes, there is Internal
Engineers that are writing internally facing
applications where your HR Department, or
your Expenses Department, Finance Department
will be using them. Then there's independent
software vendors, so ISV's that are creating
the next killer app that could be a Business
or Enterprise App. It doesn't always have
to be inward facing. So, I thought what we'd
do is we'd start with demos. And then we'll
move on, we'll talk a little bit more in depth
about the tools, the integrated set of tools
that we're providing with VMware and Spring.
We'll talk about the framework that we're
providing. So, you saw it all today when Spring
actually generated some code while it's generating
code that was based on the GWT 2.1 release.
We might as well talk a little bit about that
and understand what's going on under the hood.
And then finally at the end, we'll bring it
all together with a couple of slides to show
you how to get your application up and running
using this new framework that we built up
with Google Web Toolkit 2.1. So without further
ado, we'll jump into some demos. So when I
think of a business app from a Google standpoint,
there's one that comes to mind all the time.
And that's AdWords. It is the front end that
drives our business. While we have a lot of
things that we do in Google, one thing we
do the most is sell ads online, right? And
this is an application that allows you to
come in and generate a campaign. Say you're
pizza store, you can do pizza ads online and
you generate who you're going to target, when
you're going to target and some other demographics
about your user base. And this is all built
with Google Web Toolkit. They did a rewrite
about a year and a half ago now and they went
from doing HTML, CSS and Java Script by hand
to saying, "You know, this is a big enough
application and it means enough to the company
that we need to rewrite it using a real language."
Nothing against Java Script but when you have
a huge app--I mean, this is hundreds of thousands
of files and millions of lines and code--it
becomes much easier to maintain when it's
written in a language such as Java and you
have tools to go along with it. So stepping
out of the Google realm for a second, another
one that comes to mind is IBM Blueprint. Now,
this was previously a company called Lombardi
and they're based in the States and they were--what
they were doing was they were trying to model
business processes on the web. And this is
a great example of what usually would have
been a desktop application. And it was built
with Google Web Toolkit 2.0 and they recently
updated to 2.1 as well because they've been
following along as we've been doing development.
So I thought I bumped out and give you kind
of idea of what's going on in this application.
So here I have a new project started and I
have set--okay, in this project, I actually
have Milestone. So I have a Milestone 1 and
a Milestone 2. And what I can do is I can
move these around and still can--I want to
switch things up because this activity--at
this activity right here is tied the Milestone
1. So the list of activities I have to accomplish
to get past Milestone 1 and again, I can switch
those up. I can come on back and add a milestone.
I can edit it just like that. It's really
hard to demo with this thing right here. I
can add activity, again, clicking on it. This--there
you go and I can add the participants. I can
add up business donors, the experts. It's
not necessarily what is actually what I'm
adding to the app; it's the look and feel;
it's what I'm doing. And so, for my business,
I'm a manager and I'm trying to schedule a
whole bunch of employees to get a project
to completion, that's what I'm trying to do.
There's no reason I have to have a crummy
application that takes forever to load and
is only installed in my desktop. I should
have this available to me via the web and
it should feel like a normal desktop application.
And I think here too, the in situ effect,
the fact that everything's happening within
the one window and not jumping around to forms,
I can keep my contextual awareness. I'm more
efficient that way and that's really the power
of Google Web Toolkit. Regardless of 2.0 or
2.1 or what we're releasing from the get-go,
it's been build an app on the web and just
host it on the browser, and that's it. The
difference between a desktop application to
a web application is that we're hosting this
one in the browser. Now there are some side
effects that you can deploy it to the cloud
which is really nice but step one is getting
it off the desktop. And I think they've done
a fantastic job here of creating application
that feels like a desktop application. In
fact, so much so that they actually ended
up getting acquired by IBM so hats off to
them. So for our next example, I actually
wanted to bring up a local product manager
from a company called Webb. Otavio Silva is
going to talk about their application that
they built using Google Web Toolkit. Otavio?
>> SILVA: [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE],
Jim. This is Otavio [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
>> RAMSDALE: Thanks, Octavio. So there is
one thing about his story that resonated with
me quite well. When I originally met him--well,
jeez, about a year ago, actually--which is
that it was an existing application, existing
infrastructure, that they were able to move
over to use Google Web Toolkit. So, if you're
sitting here today and you work for a company
and you're steeped in legacy technology, don't
think there is not a chance that you could
move into making killer web apps, right? You
saw it right there. He has a typical back-end
system that like many of us have had at some
point of time when we worked for various companies.
And what they started doing was they started
carving out portions where they could use
GWT. And by segmenting it and maybe by probably
having very good design patterns as well,
they were able to say, "Okay, this portion
still goes to the existing back-end and this
portion goes to the new back-end and resulting
new front-end, which is built in the GWT."
It's an important note as I'm going to work
to the next portion of the deck. So we briefly
touched on this morning some of the integration
work that we've been doing with VMware and
Spring tools. And today while Eric Tholome
was talking about cloud portability--and I'll
bring it up one more time--I want to really
focus on developer tools. I mean, that's--that
is our core competency back in the Google
office where I come from, it's all about developer
tools. So the motivation was in fact cloud-portable
business apps. But there was an underside
part, too, which is that I just want to--I
want to see hyper-optimized business apps
running in the browser. That's really my goal.
And I share that goal with several people
back at Google; more than several. So what
we do is we take a look at the anatomy of
a typical business app, right? Now, by--these
is a broad brush stroke. I don't expect that
this is actually applicable to everything
but we said, "You know what?
There's a range of developers." First of all,
there is ISPs and enterprise developers, they
typically contain a lot of boilerplate cone,
they end up being prime for code generation.
I think we can do something about that. And
there's forms over data, usually, for the
simplistic ones and they're not optimized
for the browser, not all of them at least.
So how can we fix this? And this is going
back to Eric's point, that when we looked
at the lay of the land we looked at who was
out there. We saw Spring, we said, "You know
what, they have a set of tools that perfectly
mimics what we have." And I'm going to show
you that. But first, I want to talk about
developer lifecycle. So we said, "Okay, given
that this is the anatomy of the app, given
that this is what you're going to build or
what you have right now, what does it look
like when you build it," right? So we talked
about generating app, but we talked about
basically generating code, bootstrapping your
application, getting it up and running. Like,
how long does that take? Does it take one
day? Does it take three days? Does it take
an entire week? Like, you know, when you start
a new project and then all of a sudden your
dev manager comes along or the PM comes along--pesky
PMs--come along and they'd say, you know,
"Got a new show? It's demo day. What do you
have? What do you have," right? How long does
it take to bootstrap your application to get
going? But once you have that, you want to
iterate. You want to write some code. And
this is actually where the fun begins because
then you've got a great environment. You might
have a small team you're working and you're
just in a really fast cycle. Then you get
close to the end, you're going to start debugging,
so you want to fix some code. You want to
optimize some code, right? You're at that
last 20%, 10%, 5% of your application and
then you shift, right? So go celebrate, get
some sleep. So this is the typical development
lifecycle. For building an app that I just
showed, how do we create a set of developer
tools that make this seamless? So we look
at the tool you may know. Spring developer
tools, I've covered most of these. Spring
Roo generates codes. SpringSource Tools use
your IDE, Spring Insight is a--it's a performance
enhancing--performance enhancing, that's funny--performance
metric gathering tool that allows you to identity
sluggishness in your application; I'll talk
about that more in a second. Known as the
VMware, the parent company of Spring had a
cloud technology called vFabric that allows
you to deploy to on premise environments.
And then essentially, they had tools to build
business apps fast. Okay, so they had the
business portion in fast down. Then we looked
at what we had and we said, "We have Google
developer tools." We have Google Web Toolkit,
our Java to JavaScript compiler and code generation.
Google Plugin for Eclipse, which gets you
back in the IDE, Speed Tracer to measure sluggishness
in the browser, and then we have obviously
cloud technology, app engine for business
as well as the consumer facing app engine.
And then at that was that we have tools for
building killer web apps. So if you bring
the two together then we've accomplished what
I first set out, which is the anatomy of the
business app and the lifecycle that you're--the
developer lifecycle. So when you break it
down, you've got Spring Roo and GWT. You want
to optimize for developers, minimize boilerplate,
and ultimately get that nice Ajax feel, so
it looks you're running on--it feels like
you're running a desktop application in your
browser. When you want to iterate, when you've
moved in the cycle, use SpringSource Tools
Suite and Google Plugin for Eclipse to easily
install. It's baked into STS, so if you actually
download SpringSource Tool Suite when you
leave you'll have a dashboard where you can
immediately get our tools to get started.
So there's not a bunch of moving around to
find some STK and some plugin it's just there.
Once you have it, you can build your app fast.
Code generation refactoring quick fixes and
you can iterate quickly. As I showed off this
morning in the keynote and as well as in the
first session, in browser debugging, no compiler
phase, no deployment phase. One of the topics
that I haven't touched on was how you optimize
your application. And that's using Speed Tracer
along with backends such as app engine and
Spring Insight. And what's Spring--what Speed
Tracer does is it will--it has, like I said
in my first session, it has hooks into WebKit,
which is what Safari and Chrome are built
on top of, to actually measure things like
paint layouts, garbage collection so that
when your app starts running slow, you can
easily tell; just Speed Trace it. And then
what we have done is we've integrated that
with backend solutions, right, such as Speed
Tracer and app stats for app engine that will
give you the server side metrics, bring them
together in one unified UI to see, "Okay,
this is why it's slow in the browser. This
is why it's slow in the server. I have holistic
view. I have a roundtrip view of when it was
slow." So then finally, when you're done bootstrapping,
iterating, debugging, optimizing, you want
to deploy. And this was the goal from kind
of a high-level when we went to integrate
the two products, was that you should be able
to choose one of these to deploy to, VMware
vCloud, Google App Engine, VMware vSphere,
any other cloud. And we actually made that
happen. So I want to show one more demo before
we move on. So, how many of you are familiar
with Spring--we've been talking about it--how
of you have you actually used Spring developer
tools? All right. So there's a conference
called Spring One that happened last week
in Chicago. We went out there and had a great
time. It was my first time ever at that conference,
meeting some of the developers. But one of
the things we did was it was the first time
they were announcing hosted sequel support
coming out of app engine for business. This
is one of the things that Eric had talked
about in his keynote. It's very close to being
production-great. Right now, we're now on
a trusted tester phase. That means we've got
a beta quality version of it that we're getting
people involved in. And one of the people
we got involved in it was a Spring engineer.
We said, "You know what'd be really, really
cool? If you could take one of your Spring
apps that's never run an app engine before,
has all the Spring backend, has all the sequel
integration and you could just drop it on
an app engine, that would be proof that we've
actually accomplished our goal." And sure
enough, it'll be like maybe changing--and
I asked him 25 lines of code out of like 20,000
lines of code, had it running on a weekend.
So this is their travel app, just a basic
app that comes with Spring Web Flow, has nothing
to do with Spring Roo, has nothing to do with
Google Web Toolkit, has everything to do with
running on app engine as you can see by the
URL. It's tough for you to see in the back
but it's running off of upspot.com. This is
the hotel application, it's a travel application.
And so, I can go in and I can search for hotels,
so maybe in Chicago. And there you go. I've
actually queried a SQL backend hosted in our
cloud and I can--I brought back up a result
and I can click on that. Here we go, view
hotels, sorry about that. Brings up that.
I can say, "Book It." Okay. I'm going to pick
my date and I want non-smoking, ocean view--and
I don't have a fake credit card number right
now. But you can see it's querying the system
right now and pulling back the results. All
you had to do--this is the nice part, all
you had to do is to get this happen besides
tweaking a few lines of code, was replaced
the JDBC driver that he was using and a connection
string. That was it. So when we talk about
these things being cloud-portable we're really
serious about it and this is proof positive
that this is actually going on. So the framework,
the new Google 2.1 release. So when the Spring
Roo goes off and generates a whole bunch of
code as you saw this morning, it's going to
generate that code for something, right, and
it's going to generate for some framework.
And what we've done is Spring, and a lot of
the enterprise community are built on top
of the MVC patterns, so the model-view controller
pattern. It's great. It's fantastic. It scales
well. But it doesn't quite work perfectly
for web apps. Basically, what you got to do
is you got to tweak it a bit and separate
your view and controller codes just a tad
bit more for testability reasons and for performance
reasons. But for all intent and purposes if
I say MVP, just think MVC and you'll be okay.
So what we knew is that Spring Roo was already
generating this MVC-type application. And
as your best practices, we said that this
is perfect. We used these best practices entirely.
We just haven't codified them. We haven't
pulled them into a framework themselves, right?
What we do is you have people like me and
engineers--others engineers and a GWT team
going around saying like, "You know, if you
want to build big applications, you should
go do dah, dah, dah, dah." And we'd rattle
off like three different things you needed
to do. So we said, "We should take those best
practices and pull them into a framework,"
and that's exactly what we did. We did quite
a few other things, too. So let's go over
those. So when we talk about Google Web Toolkit
it's really comprised of three main products;
Google Plugin for Eclipse, Speed Tracer and
a Google Web Toolkit SDK. Some minor enhancements
to the top two, so from the Google Plugin
for Eclipse, we now have browser profiles.
So this morning you saw me right-click on
that URL and I could pick Firefox or Safari.
And very soon we'll have support for Chrome
and Mac as well. It's pretty nice, nice little
enhancement. It was actually requested quite
a bit like, "Jeez, why can't I just launch
a browser from inside the IDEs instead of
copying and pasting?" Well now, you can. The
one I like the most and the one that was--the
one feature we got the most out of the integration
with Spring was we had to fix our Maven support.
So I hate to keep asking, but how many people
actually use Maven? Yes, that's what I thought.
Okay. So there's a lot, a lot of people that
use Maven out there. And it's tough because
Maven doesn't always work well with IDEs.
And actually it doesn't really work well with
Google Web Toolkit or Google App Engine SDKs,
simply because there's a structure to our
SDKs when you actually unzip it. And I urged
you if you don't have--if you haven't download
the SDKs, go do it. But when you unzip it,
you'll notice that there's a structure to
them and Maven has its own structure. When
those two structures don't align, well things
kind of go array. So what we did is we said,
"Okay, well, we own the tools, we can fix
this." And so with some help from some Spring
guys, we moved some special code that they
had in STS, in SpringSource Tool Suite into
Google plug--into the Google Plugin for Eclipse.
So now, you can actually have Maven projects
imported seamlessly into Eclipse or SpringSource
Tool Suite depending on which IDE you're using.
Speed Tracer 1.0, I actually--I talked briefly
about this but you can do a roundtrip speed
tracing, so client to backend see holistically
a view of your application. Another minor
update with the UI, you can launch it from
the Google Plugin for Eclipse, so there's
a notion of just integrating products, not
just us integrating with Speed Tracer or--us
integrating with Spring and VMware, but us
integrating our own products as well just
to give you a seamless experience. But let's
get to the goods. So the GWT SDK got some
major, major updates and a major overhaul.
And what we did was we said, "This is the
framework that I'm talking about." Activities
and places, request factory, editors, and
cell-based widgets. These are the four main
topics that we--or the four main features
we added to the GWT SDK. What are these? I'm
glad you've asked. So, Activities and Places
was our formal name for this MVC/MVP framework.
Activities equal presenters. And to keep the
analogy going, if you're from the MVC world,
activities kind of equal the controllers of
your application. That's truly were the business
logic of your application goes, right? And
in the places equal views, so that's your
widget code, that's what's displaying the
tables, and the buttons, and the layout, and
the--overall, it's a mechanism from getting
for one view to another, right? So when you
talk about hyper-optimizing an application,
there's this notion of reusable code and when
you have to initialize things and when you
don't. When you have a large application,
if you go through and you initialize all your
views at once, you can imagine that kind of
makes for a sluggish start-up time. So when
you use this framework, then we'll actually
lays--we initialize that for you, things like
your places, and your views, and all your
widgets, and then in your app your application
is snappy. So, RequestFactory. I mean, from
the get-go with Google Web Toolkit, one of
the things we prioritized on was, well, one,
how much AJAX we're using, right? So under
the covers there's a lot of calls going back
and forth even though you stay on the same
screen. This is updating up here, this is
updating this table, your left hand nav might
update and you don't know it, so it's all
happening under the hood. So, given the fact
that we're doing so many AJAX calls, we realize
that we wanted to be super optimized with
these and we want to make it easy for you
to call them. So we've done this with RequestFactory,
it allows you to work with light weight proxy
objects. Another term for these are DTOs,
Data Transfer Objects. So you want to think
model, domain objects and DTOs, and going
back to the previous analogy, the model, that's
just the model. So that--no matter if you're
using MVP or MVC, your model is your model,
it's your data. It's how you describe the
things that are getting passed back and forth
in your application. Your domain objects are
your entities, that would be like the employee,
or the expense, or the report that I was talking
about this morning. And then DTOs are just
proxy objects, the light weight ones. The
idea there is this, the takeaway, imagine
if you had a list of contacts and I was--in
your contact, it was actually, let's say 70
fields deep, right? If you can remember--have
you--you guys have used Microsoft Outlook,
right? That thing is widely extensible and
it has all these fields, and if I want to
make a fetch, especially with my phone, I
don't want all 70 fields I just want the top
10 that I can display, right? So we have to
have a way for them to optimize that so you
get only what you can display and we did that
here. If I may, we--while we were in a process
of building this framework for you to create
your application and we realize that like,
"Well, what good is a framework when you can't
edit, view and edit the data?" So we said,
"You know what, let's build--we'll build out
some editors." And what we do is we give you
the ability to take an entity. So again, let's
go back and say, your employee, and with just
annotations you can annotate it and we'll
create a view for you, so--and you just plug
it into your application. Given that we give
you some baseline UI, they can be customized
and they can be wired at the proxy objects
for--in request factory. So there's a notion
that, "I told you that this is how you show
this entity, this employee object," but I
can also say to my editor, "This is how you're
going to get change sets." So if you're doing
Chris Ramsdale, the employee, and some other
portion of the application makes a change,
gets synced up to the server, the server sends
back down a change update like that my Social
Security number, or let's say my mobile phone
number has changed, that editor that's displaying
me, my employee record, will be updated automatically
for you. And it only have built-in validation
too. So, if you say your phone number is a
phone number and a phone number has to be
numbers, you can build that in to the framework
itself, you can build that into the editor
so that we can check to see if you put any
alphanumeric characters or alphabetic characters,
or that your phone number is of some certain
size. The cell-based widgets are a nice one.
So these were--if there's one thing we've
learned over the years is that, do you ever
see widgets can be kind of heavy weight and
the reason they're heavy weight is because
they're doing all of the sinking for events.
So I drop a table on there and I put some
buttons in the cell, and then I put some--another
table inside, another cell, that it just--all
of a sudden you end up with about 255 widgets
on your page and they're all listening for
events. And when an event comes in, we have
to go traverse the tree to find out who to
send it to and it gets slow and sluggish.
And we found this out with AdWords really
quickly. So we said, "You know what, the way
to solve this is we'll just have a container
and inside the container, we have a whole
bunch of divs and when you want to actually
generate some UI, we'll generate it with HTML,
we just stick it inside that div. So it's
very, very light weight. So what you end up
with is a huge table on your screen, right?
Displaying all kinds of data but really it's
only one widget, it's the container that's
listening for events. And the container is
smart enough to know that when he gets the
event, it looks for some special properties
and it can traverse its tree on it's own,
a very small tree that is, and find the div,
give it to the div, and then he can take care
of it from there. So again, minimize event
handling overhead, captured by a parent container,
relying on safe HTML. That was another one
too, is that given the fact that we're injecting
HTML into these divs, it's got to be safe.
So we've introduced a new component within
GWT 2.1 that allows you to have safe HTML.
And if you don't know what that is, that's
basically so that you can't inject JavaScript
into your page so it'll check it for you beforehand,
before you actually put it into your table.
And then just because of all this, because
we've kept it lightweight, because we've kept
it hyper-optimized for the desktop, we get
optimization for the mobile right off the
bat. So now, I'm giving you the overview of
the framework. I thought we'd take a few slides
just to bring it all together, right? To bring,
"Okay, you've told me about all these things.
How do I actually do something with them now,"
right? Now, I'll tell you, the best way to
do it is to actually go and download the SDK.
Go and download the tools, we have documentation
online, and go and run through some of the
samples. But what I'll try to do is in a matter
of the remaining 10 minutes here to step you
through what's going on and then feel free,
we'll probably leave five minutes to do some
Q&A. So putting the pieces together, one of
the three steps. We have app startup, kind
of have to have that, right? We get a requesting
data because what good is your application
if you don't have some valuable data inside
of it. And then if you get the data we have
to display it, right? Pretty trivial. This
has to happen. So let's see how we put these
pieces together. So for app startup, the first
thing you're going to start off with is an
activity manager. This is going to be the
person that gets you around in your application,
all right? So here's an activity mapper. So
if I have an activity manager, right, that's
the core of getting around my application.
My activity mapper gets me from a place back
to an activity. Now what's a place? A place
is simply a spot in your application, right?
Hence the name, "place." "I want to go here.
Okay. Well, give me the activity that gets
me to this view. I want to go view the details
of an employee. Great, that's a new place.
Tell me the activity that gets me there."
So you have an activity mapper. Now, typically,
and like, remember the application I showed
today where we had a simple left-hand nav
and then we had a table that's actually showing
some values. That left-hand nav is getting
me to different spots of my application. So
how do I show it? I actually get a display
panel. A display panel is just a widget that
show that navigation and you set that view,
that set display, on the activity manager.
Okay, so now I need a place controller, right?
I need somebody that's actually going to take
care of when I invoke the "I want to go here,"
he has to get that. And the place controller
is the guy that's going to coordinate, notifying
everybody else that the user wants to go to
another place. Mind you. The activity manager
can get me there. The place controller is
going to notify the rest of the application.
Then you have a place history handler. So
remember how I mentioned that you get history
support right out of the box, that's because
we have a place history handler. And what
that does is that's going to take a bookmark
or a URL that has a hashtag that's basically
a place in your application and it's going
to turn it into a place request. And the way
it does that is the place history handler
says, "Okay. I know how to generate your place
based on a URL that you've given me or a bookmark,
but I don't know what to do with it. So, what
do I do?" I need to know about the place controller
so I could tell the place controller, "Hey,
he just had a bookmark and I need to go to
this place." So they register via that mechanism.
Now, we've got all this happening on the top,
how do we get them to notify each other, right?
So from GWT 2.0 and on, we have this thing
called the event bus which allows you to pass
requests and events back and forth. So we
have an event bus. And then they all hook
into it and it's hunky-dory, right? So everybody's
tied together but how do we actually get events?
What are the events that pass back and forth?
Okay, so when we move everything else. We
just simply say, "Okay, these two are the
important parts, the place controller and
the activity manager." Again, I want to go
somewhere, I'll tell the place controller.
The activity manager says, "I can get you
there." So how did they do that? It's actually
quite simple. When I want to go somewhere
I simply, my application, calls go to on the
place controller and hands it a place. "Go
to this record. Show me the details." The
place controller says, "That's great." It
takes that place, wraps it up into event,
fires a place change request for you. And
again, this is all part of the framework happening
under the covers. Puts it on the event bus
and then the activity manager picks it up
and says, "Great. I know how to handle a place
change request." So it takes that place change
request event, gets the place out of it, calls
the activity mapper and says, "Hey, you know
how to map places to activities, tell me what
activity goes with this." The activity mapper
says, "Hey, this is great. This is the record
detail activity that you need." He says, "Great."
He gets back an activity. Now, this is the
guy that's actually going to take this and
put up a view on your screen, you know? What
happens is the activity manager says, "Thanks
for the activity, activity mapper. I'm going
to call start on this guy. I'm going to pass
him a panel." And a panel is nothing more
than a container where you can start drawing
in the event bus because you're going to have
to get some of the events back and forth.
So at that point in time, that's when you
start getting your view up. The activator--the
activity says, "Start, it get--" start gets
a call on it and says, "I know how to draw
inside of a panel." So now that you have that
initial view up, how do you go and request
data, right? So now and right now all I have
is an empty screen. So this is where code
generation really, really takes on. This is
some of the power of Google Web Toolkit. So
I start with an employee list activity, right?
And what this is, is this is an activity,
as I mentioned before, but it's specific to
listing. And it's specific to listing certain
types of objects. In this case, my employee,
right? Now the framework is going to call
in that and say, "I need a range of objects.
I need the first 10 employees. Get those for
me," because the rest of the application doesn't
know how to do it. They're like, "I don't
know. I just know they need 10 employees,
employed list activity. Find them for me."
Again, the activities are the brains of your
application. It's where all the core code
goes. So the list of activity says, "You know
what, I know about this thing called a request
factory," right? And I know that request factories
will get request for me to my back end to
issue the data to me." So, he has a request
factory. In fact, he's initialized with the
request factory. And he says, "Okay. Give
me the employee request because I need to
get the first 10 employees." Request factory
says, "Cool. No problem. I know about--I know
how to give you back an employee request and
I also know what concrete class this is linked
to on the server side." Because at the end
of the day, I can talk about code generation,
all this magic that happens, but you got to
do a sequel call to get data out of your database,
right, to get it back to your application.
So right now, this is all on the client side.
So the list of activities says, "Request factory,
get me an employee request," he gets one,
goes through some generated code to call find
all. It's kind of tough to read there. It's
"list employee proxy find all," give me all
the employees. And call some generated code,
that's generated by the GWIT compiler and
code generators, that's the magic, and finally
gets to your employee class on the server
side. So this blue box on the right-hand side
for you is actually server side code that's
going to run. And you can tell because it's
got a select start from sequel call, right?
And that gets back a list of employees. Then
what it's going to do is it's going to pass
it back through the generated code. The generated
code is going to take care of serializing
all of those employees, right? Some big array
of employee records down to some JSON format
and pass it back to you. And then what you
get, viola, is a list of employee proxies.
And then you're like, "Hold on. Wait a second.
So I actually ask for employees, why am I
getting back employee proxies?" That goes
back to the whole the employee proxy is the
light weight version of your employee. You
can define which fields you want. But the
point here, the real takeaway is that you
asked for a list of employees and didn't have
to worry about what the JSON payload looked
like, all the serialization code, you just
got back a list of employee proxies. And you
can start iterating over them and doing whatever
you want to do. You have your data now and
it feels like an object. So now, this gets
really easy. So I now I want to display this,
right? So I could iterate through this and
I could, you know, pick apart fields and everything.
But we have this nice piece of the framework
where once you have this list all you have
to do is you have a list view. Now in this
case, list view is an abstract class. So you
derive from it, and I have my employee list
view, that's specific to my application but
you get a bunch of helper methods along with
that. So my employee list activity that now
has a list of employee proxies. A list of
employee DTO says, "Cool. I'm going to give
to list view to show it. Because I am a--I'm
an activity. I don't know about widgets. I
don't know how the screen's constructed. I
don't even know if I'm talking to a mobile
view or a desktop view. But I know that I'm
going to give it to this view and they'll
take care of it." The employee list view said,
"This is great." Now, if you follow MVC enough,
you know there's one key rule that your views
really don't know about your data model or
your views don't know about your business
logic, they're really dumb views, right? All
they know how to do is to take some data,
put it on the screen and be done with it.
So how do you do that? How do you give the
employee list view a set of objects that it
doesn't know anything about? How does it know
how to parse those to get the fields out so
that column one is my first name, column two
is my last name and then column three is my
mobile number? That's easy. What you do is
you have an outside entity that actually knows
about your data model, knows about some of
your business logic and it says, "Look, Mr.
employee list view, I know that you don't
know much about the world but I'm going to
tell you how to separate this record that
comes back and where the--what column to put
the
data
in based on the fields." And all it does is
it calls add column and gives it, "Okay. For
the first column, it's going to be the name.
You're going to have an abstract cell, that's
going to be the cell you actually draw into,
and I'm going to pass you a get-value method,"
right? This is an anonymous inner class that
knows how to get the data out of the employee
proxies. So that the view never knows. It
simply iterates over its columns and says,
"Okay. Column zero, here's an employee proxy.
You tell me what the value is." And that code
that knows how to dissect that lives back
inside of the activity realm so it knows about
data models and things like that. So it's
a way of getting your entity broken up on
the screen without violating some of the principles
of MVC and MVP. And then finally, when it's
all said and done, you have a screen that
looks like this. And this is the real app
that we demoed at Google IO. Where you have
taken apart an expense report--yeah, it sounds
like we're big on expense reports, I get it.
But we take apart an expense report, and you
have the purpose, the notes, the department,
and it create it. And what I just showed you
is exactly how that view is brought up right
now. So that's really about the first 10%
of it. And then there's a whole much more
afterwards so, again, I encourage you to go
download the SDK. Check out the documentation
and then we have a wildly active developer
forum. So I think we're up to roughly 23,000
users at this point in time so there's a lot
of you out there. We're out there. Go check
it out. Thanks.